Houston,
uh,
you said that kicks in Greenley and pineapple did,
you know,
prior map works with pineapple once he,
he used to do,
he would drive all the way across Houston to ignore me.
That's what he did it,
he did it all the time and he had no reason to be there.
And I,
and I know that some of those guys that didn't like me because I don't,
I dunno why,
but they were really,
really clickish and I went in there one night and had a horrible set and a,
and I was following Hicks and uh,
you know,
and I have a really green show,
but in the right circumstance,
you know,
in a comedy club with nothing great happening before you,
it kind of worked a little bit that night and didn't work at all.
And uh,
but and I was probably getting a little more work than those guys were,
some of them.
And they're like,
oh,
he sucks.
Well,
the fact of the matter is I did suck because of my act with,
uh,
you know,
you don't want to follow [inaudible].
I say that to make the story better.
I wasn't following Hicks,
but he was,
you know,
or Kennison but they were both there.
Oh,
okay.
No,
I had done said,
but everybody was good.
I mean the green leaves good.
All these guys,
we're seasoned pros.
So that was a hotline up and uh,
but,
but I never felt,
you know,
like they get him like me except for headaches.
And I came to see him,
you know,
do,
do shows and uh,
uh,
I asked him to do the story about,
just John Davidson and the mask and he goes,
here's what he says.
He goes,
don't stand next to the exit is just a tip.
Cause people just walk out of the show.
When he died,
watched him do that.
He,
he uh,
he did that at the Nick's comedy stop in Boston and he cleared the fucking room
man.
And it was,
it was crazy because at the end of the show there was me and Greg Fitzsimmons
and then maybe three or four other comics of five or six people in the crowd.
There was like maybe 20 people left,
all told,
laughing our fucking asses.
Right.
Everybody else is getting up angry.
I saw it go both ways.
You know,
I've seen him beat crowds to death.
Uh,
I saw the set one night at the last stop and Austin and nobody in the room could
breathe and he was in the mood to do it.
And Eh,
you know,
and you know,
and,
and I think sometimes he was,
sometimes he wasn't or whatever,
but he was in the mood and decided to just fucking stab us all in the face.
And it was just,
it was beautiful.
He was exceptional.
Now whether or not people think he was one of the greats,
like
that's entirely subjection.
Subjectual right?
It's subjective.
Rather you'd say it's completely up to your own interpretation.
But to me he changed comedy and a lot of ways because he,
people talk about things that were important because everybody else was talking
about nonsense.
You're talking about airline food and how come I can't lean my seat back?
Standard normal shit.
I'm following it up.
Exactly right.
And he was coming along talking about a positive drug stories.
You know,
a man on acid realize it all matters,
manage energy condensed to a slow rhythmic vibration.
Like that whole fucking bit was here's Tom with the weather app.
That was amazing.
Yeah,
no,
it was anyways,
influential.
I mean,
I know,
I think I can say this about Bill Hicks and I am an expert at stand up comedy.
I would have a triple doctorate in,
uh,
if you gave those kinds of things for the work.
I've,
their amount of time I've put into [inaudible] and a,
and a,
and you as a peer would have the exact same thing.
So for me to listen to someone's opinion about standup comedy,
they have to have a lot of credit to me before I really give a shit what they
think.
Okay.
So here's what you should think.
The only thing that every comic from my generation agrees on is he was better
than us.
And that's the only thing that they agree on.
And,
and they,
and I can't find anybody that has a big argument that he wasn't,
and that was the,
the,
the best that ever lived.
No.
But did he influenced me more than anybody else.
And you probably more than anybody else because you're certainly that way also,
you know,
write some look.
Somebody built that bridge.
Yes.
And you,
and now you feel free to talk about anything,
you know,
none of yours act as ever hack.
You know,
there were a lot of hacks,
but I think it's freed people not to be a hack,
you know?
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he cured people that he made it shameful,
you know,
are talking about hat,
but there was also,
and then you're,
you're cured above ceiling material.
So I don't know if I did I,
yeah.
Well,
I think it's still going on.